[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP on va parler
cuisine on va parler alimentation
agriculture écologique autour d'un plat
et d'un dessert choisi par notre invité
et cette semaine nous recevons Thomas
ménager bonjour bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à table et avec
moi pour présenter cette émission bien
sûr Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour
Jean-Pierre bonjour monsieur bénager
vous êtes député rassemblement national
du Loiret mais cadre dans l'immobilier
de profession vous avez été élu parmi
les 90 députés RN de la vague de 2022 et
vous êtes le tombeur de l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Jean-Michel Blanquer vous avez vite
trouvé votre place à l'Assemblée en tant
que porte-parole de votre groupe et
orateur sur le projet de loi retraite
mais malgré votre jeune âge vous êtes
loin d'être un novice en politique en
quartier d'abord à l'UMP vous soutenez
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 avant de
rejoindre Nicolas Dupont-Aignan en 2014
vous vous séparez pour désaccord
stratégiques en 2017 faute d'accord avec
le RN pour les législatives
comme je le disais vous n'êtes pas
novice alors laissez-moi penser que le
choix du plat est peut-être un message
politique à votre circonscription
Jean-Pierre oui je ne sais pas
exactement mais en tous les cas on va se
régaler de tomates farcies et en dessert
d'une tarte tatin dans le dessous des
plats la France va-t-elle réduire
l'élevage de bovins comme le préconise
la Cour des comptes les éleveurs se
Rebit reportage dans cette émission dans
les pieds dans le plat l'inquiétude des
producteurs de betterave à sucre qui ne
peuvent plus utiliser des pesticides la
Cour européenne a dit non à de nouvelles
dérogations
on passe la suite cuisine et confidence
alors Thomas ménager cela nous a pas
échappé que demander des tomates farcies
début juin est une pure hérésie si
jamais vous aviez vu un écolo il vous
l'aurait dit pour le RN pourtant encore
un peu vert sur les questions écolo il a
bien compris que le respect de la
saisonnalité des produits fait
aujourd'hui partie du service minimum
cela dit cette obsession pour les
tomates début juin nous ramène peut-être
à des arrière-pensées de saison plus
politique gourmande et oui pensons à ces
fameuses tomates que le peuple Brigitte
que vous dites incarnez lancé la guerre
au théâtre sur les comédiens si la pièce
ne leur plaisait pas et la pièce que
vous détestez aujourd'hui est celle des
retraites alors peut-être que vous dites
que des tomates plus des casseroles
pourrait peut-être faire reculer
Emmanuel Macron je ne sais pas au fond
si vous validez cette embout politique
voilà pourquoi donc pour retomber sur
mes pattes je me dis aussi que cette
envie du jour et peut-être très loin de
toutes ces supputations et s'il
s'agissait juste de rendre un hommage et
pour cela il n'a pas de saison à une
grand-mère dont les tomates farcies
est une tuerie absolue oui vous êtes
allé vraiment beaucoup trop loin c'est
vrai qu'en politique et quand on fait
votre émission on se pose des questions
faut pas faire semblant je pense que
tout le monde le sait on se dit comment
quelle image on veut donner qui qui on
est vraiment parce que en fait ça ça dit
beaucoup de choses mais non on n'est pas
le cheval aussi loin et c'était tout
simplement parce que c'est un message
politique non c'est pas un message
politique c'est juste un souvenir
personnel une émotion personnelle
alors c'est pas ma grand-mère c'est ma
mère tout court et c'est mon enfance
c'est-à-dire que moi je viens de milieu
rural petit je repiquais les tomates
avec mon père on avait des des centaines
de pieds de tomates c'est à dire c'était
les bocaux de ratatouille elle est
beaucoup de sauce tomate et les plus
grosses bah c'était les tomates farcies
dimanche quand on faisait on garde les
plus grosses bah ouais celles qui sont
les plus belles les plus ronde et plus
ronds les plus belles celles qui ont eu
beaucoup de chance quand elle se sont
quand elles sont construit quand elles
ont poussé et puis bah on fait ces
tomates farcies on met du riz à les
préparer ou pas je faisais vraiment
toute la chaîne vraiment de tout en haut
à l'assiette de la
exactement bah c'est comme ça beaucoup
on ruralité alors on avait un peu
ras-le-bol des tomates pour être honnête
en famille les salades de tomates et
tout les périodes d'été on avait un peu
ras-le-bol parce que bah oui on
respectait la saisonnalité parce que
c'était moins cher c'est un petit peu
tôt non j'avoue que j'ai pas réfléchi au
message politique vous voyez c'est pour
ça que je vous disiez trop loin sur le
côté ouais
je sais aujourd'hui on est vite condamné
vite au pilori ce genre de choses mais
bon il y en a qui on a pas non plus fait
une orgie de tomate donc oui on a on a
fait euh sur les étages les premières
tomates à mon avis c'est quand même
encore de la tomate sous serre
aujourd'hui malheureusement si peu
totalement de France alors moi je
pensais un message politique parce que
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une foire à la
tomate à reuilly-sur-loire non la tomate
farcie même circonscription
de la tomate farcie il y a des forts de
la tomate farcie c'est peut-être un
souvenir de pas un signe c'était pas un
signal non c'est vraiment parce que
c'est un plat que j'aime déjà je me
serais pas forcé à manger un plat que
j'aimais pas dans la compétition des
tomates farcies on allait pas on
n'allait pas aussi loin mon père était
un fou furieux et toujours un fou
furieux du jardin c'est à dire que en
fait on produit 15 fois plus que ce
qu'on mange c'est à dire que ça nourrit
les copains les voisins qui passent à la
maison
c'est 1500 mètres carrés donc ça
l'occupe bien en parallèle de son boulot
et c'est vrai que il me réquisitionnait
quand j'étais petit alors maintenant
j'ai plus la chance de pouvoir faire un
potager mais c'est quelque chose que je
sais faire que j'apprécie et donc
j'ai les bases je suis pas sûr d'avoir
cette ce dont il est je suis pas un
agriculteur ou je suis pas non plus un
spécialiste mais clairement j'ai jardiné
toute ma vie mon père m'a mis quand
j'étais petit dans le jardin ça faisait
partie de l'éducation j'ai absolument
pas le suivi le cursus mon père artisan
mais au moins ça je savais le faire
justement c'est intéressant de savoir
comment vous consommez aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous achetez ce que vous
faites très attention aux produits si
vous avez directement à l'école alors
attendez on va goûter parce que là je
suis en train de poser beaucoup de
questions on va goûter cette tomate
farcie préparer par chez Françoise ça
peut supporter un peu la température
tiède les tomates enfin même froid donc
c'est bien
avec tes premières chaleurs là qui
arrivent et donc si elle ressemble aux
Mathes farcies de votre maman mais bon
là
on y est jamais parce que en plus
au-delà du goût dont on a souvent une
idéalise des goûts d'enfance donc dans
tous les cas on y arrive pas mais elle
est très très bonne c'est vrai que nous
on rajoutait on rajoute un peu de mie de
pain pour essayer de rendre ça un peu
plus un peu plus léger parce que c'est
vrai que la chasse aussi alors
maintenant il y en a qui vont le faire
du bœuf du porc non on peut on mélange
de légumes maintenant
il faut utiliser vous l'avez dit des
grosses tomates bien rondes mais moi
j'aime bien aussi les petites tomates
pour faire les farcis niçois le petit
singe le plus difficile mais
effectivement il faut privilégier où il
y a une chair qui est facile à enlever
on l'enlève avec une petite cuillère
pour faire des petites des petites
boules c'est plus simple on sale pour
enlever l'eau et puis effectivement il
faut mettre du bœuf du veau un peu de
gras avec le porc mais on peut rajouter
aussi du fromage de la ricotta et puis
quand on les fait cuire il faut qu'elle
soit bien serré dans votre plat un petit
filet d'huile d'olive 40 minutes au four
à 160 180 puis vous remettez les petits
chapeaux à la fin alors c'était parti
c'était pas light c'était pas like mais
nous on rajoutait du riz qui permettait
de plonger le gras et bon c'est super
gratuit mais ça se fait beaucoup dans la
tomate farcie mais donc ça en fait un
plat complexe bien complet on a tout ce
qu'il faut aller protéines par exemple
en Turquie font beaucoup tout ce qui est
tomates farcies oignons farcis
aubergines farcies farcies mais beaucoup
de riz si on n'a pas trop ça peut être
assez intéressant du coup ça fait un
plat complet alors du coup comment vous
consommez vous aujourd'hui puisque vous
avez été élevé comme ça en piquant les
tomates et est-ce que vous avez
directement à la ferme est-ce que vous
faites très attention à la traçabilité
des produits là encore on aimerait être
parfait en la matière on essaie de faire
tous des efforts moi je fais super gaffe
surtout à l'origine parce que je crois
bien entendu à l'écriture biologique
mais je crois que c'est pas la panacée
parce que parfois il y a du bio qui
vient de l'autre bout du monde et dont
le bilan global carbone n'est pas
forcément excellent donc je fais gaffe
sauf aujourd'hui quand même à la
saisonnalité en plus maintenant il y a
dans un certain nombre de supermarchés
au-delà des marchés où là on a quand
même la capacité de juger plus
facilement il y a aussi maintenant des
affichages qu'il faudrait peut-être
essayer d'augmenter sur la sérénité pour
savoir parce que c'est vrai que vous
vous êtes un spécialiste donc vous savez
que c'était pas la bonne période
exactement à quel à quelle saison ouais
ils sont proposés dans les états on sait
pas bien si on fait une bêtise ou pas il
faudrait effectivement avoir beaucoup de
choses
c'est vrai que bon pour les peut-être
les jeunes ruraux qui sont encore dans
dans les champs ou qui sont encore au
contact comme moi je l'étais on est un
peu plus sensibilisé mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a du travail à faire après on
essaie bien sûr circuit court on essaie
de faire le marché mais la réalité quand
on est député et ça faut aussi être
honnête c'est que on joue aussi la
rapidité la simplicité et que parfois
c'est le drive vite fait récupérer le
dimanche soir pour te dire le McDo il va
manger
[Musique]
on va pas pousser son caddie on va pas
forcément prendre le temps d'aller au
marché alors on y va parfois souvent en
plus on y va on parle donc c'est pas
toujours le meilleur moyen de réellement
faire ses courses et donc voilà il y a
aussi le rythme de la vie du député ou
faut pas faire croire à ce qui nous
écoutent tout le temps
d'aller chiner les bons produits au bon
moment et euh pardon une frustration
pour vous de pas cuisiner ça fait partie
alors je sais quand même moi j'adore ça
parce qu'en plus ça permet de se vider
la tête j'aime ça je suis pas voilà j'ai
appris les bases en famille encore une
fois après quelquefois j'essaie de
prendre ce temps moi le petit plaisir
que je me suis fait par contre là depuis
que je suis député c'est le seul chose
où je me suis fait vraiment un cadeau et
un plaisir alors je sais que ça sera pas
populaire là encore grossière erreur
technique
c'est que je me suis acheté un barbecue
un énorme barbecue à la fois à gaz et et
au chat au charbon je sais que Madame
Rousseau si regarde cette émission je
lui demande de me pardonner mais j'aime
bien parce qu'en fait quoi qu'on en dise
la nourriture c'est aussi un moment
d'échange et c'est le moment où vider la
tête passer à autre chose c'est un peu
peut-être
il y a des femmes qui adorent le
barbecue je pense que il y a voilà c'est
juste un moment d'échange qui s'en
occupent c'est ce que dénoncé aussi
Sandrine Rousseau après on peut mettre
des légumes sur un barbecue on n'est pas
possible
il y a pas que voilà il y a la côte de
bœuf c'est très sympa on veut être un
peu plus politique mon correct on peut
dire j'ai un j'ai une plancha ou un
barbecue mais je ne fais que des
courgettes non je ne fais pas des
courgettes mais il y a des courgettes il
y a des poivrons c'est pas
automatiquement le truc de viandard
historique mais je pense qu'il y a des
femmes qui aiment le barbecue je pense
que franchement ça c'était une polémique
totalement débile mais il y avait
d'autres spécialités qu'on mangeait à la
maison autres ces tomates farcies
c'était des plats assez traditionnels ou
ouais je vais pas réinventer c'est vrai
que c'était une famille traditionnelle
ou je pense que ma mère a repris mon
père ont tous les deux repris les
plaques eux-mêmes mangeaient la
blanquette de veau les salles
bourguignon une poule au pot c'est vrai
moi j'avais la chance d'être à la
campagne alors ça me mettait un petit
peu mal à l'aise parce que je voyais à
la fois les lapins et les poules ils
finissaient dans mon assiette donc il y
a eu quelques moments où à un âge où
j'avais la capacité de comprendre ce que
je mangeais où j'étais un peu en
rébellion c'était le petit lapin qui est
découvert la veille qui avait dans les
terriers dans les voilà j'allais le voir
sans poil alors souvent végétarien pour
eux végétarien pour autant alors souvent
ils avaient pris la technique mes
parents de le mettre au congel et
d'attendre un petit peu comme ça
j'oubliais le petit lapin que j'avais
disparu ils essayaient de me ménager
sans mauvais jeu de mots à l'époque déjà
et donc clairement voilà c'était ça
après c'était moi je sais que mon père
adorait adore toujours il savait plus
mais faire des désolé
à ce qu'il faisait l'andouille de sarjo
ou de
pareil là je vais pas raconter moi je
suis alors
c'est de la région c'est la même région
Centre c'est la région Centre moi j'ai
fait un bon pour me rapprocher de mon
travail il y a 5 ans dans le Loiret et
donc c'est juste à côté de Jargeau c'est
une andouille une spécialité locale
voilà la meilleure puisqu'elle vient de
mon département on va dire mais mais
voilà après c'est ça fait partie de ces
spécialités que nous avons on a une
région qui a beaucoup de richesses mais
on a encore du travail pour faire
connaître les spécialités de la région
Centre parce que il y a moins d'identité
pour être honnête que dans d'autres
régions où il y a des plats qui ont
réussi à dépasser les frontières
d'autres à part cette andouille
alors moi sur le Gâtinais il y a il y a
une spécialité historique qui est le
miel parce qu'en fait ça remonte à une
époque il y avait une plante qui
s'appelait saint foin qui était une
plante militaire très importante alors
aujourd'hui qui était pour les bêtes
mais dites-moi c'est très dingue parce
que moi on parle du miel du Gâtinais
près de Fontainebleau aussi ouais c'est
sur trois départements Seine-et-Marne
Yon et eloiré la plus grosse partie
c'est ma circonscription et voilà donc
mais bon on est on est passé clair et il
y a sûrement du très bon
on en parlera peut-être par rapport au
néonicotini il se porte bien entendu il
faut préserver et développer
l'apiculture il y a l'apiculture
professionnelle l'apiculture amateur la
plupart des apiculteurs sont des
apiculteurs amateurs et ça ça fait
partie de mes petits projets je suis
allé il y a maintenant une quinzaine de
jours faire mon initiation
en apiculture et j'espère sera vraiment
le moment de se vider la tête avoir mes
trois premières ruches l'année prochaine
pour je sais quand on est député moi je
je découvre je suis un jeune député on a
besoin de ces phases de décompression et
donc ça fait partie des choses sur
lesquelles alors je pense qu'il y a
aussi une volonté de se dépasser j'ai
enlevé le gant j'ai réussi à toucher la
colonie sanguin ça pique pas la seule
problème c'est que je sais pas encore si
je fais allergique parce que j'ai pas le
souvenir de Netflix piqué donc peut-être
que voilà ma femme comme parlementaire
sera une fin étrange pas on verra ce qui
se passera mais dans tous les cas
l'année prochaine j'espère et je
travaille quand même plus tard pour me
former un gros consommateur de miel vous
personnellement alors consomme j'en
consomme beaucoup en hiver mais pour des
questions plutôt médicales j'adore ça
aussi mais parce que en fait parce que
j'ai j'ai problème d'angine c'est vrai
que c'est un très bon médicament très
bon avec un peu de lait chaud c'est
naturel et c'est très bon donc on arrive
à joindre l'utile à l'agréable et donc
je suis un consommateur moyen je suis
pas je ne fais pas que manger du miel
mais c'est plutôt moi les abeilles
l'organisation qui qui me passionne et
cette capacité qu'on a eu aussi à
domicile cette organisation des abeilles
voilà sauf que le fourmis est produit
rien qu'on peut manger de manière
agréable donc c'est un peu de viande
sous les sacs que ça crée sucré salé
avec du miel par exemple alors là je
vais revenir au barbecue une chose que
j'adore faire très marinade au miel
c'est très bon alors moi je fais des
ribs je mets du miel sauce soja miel un
peu de sauce un peu de ketchup et je les
laisse mariner et après au barbecue
c'est très très bon c'est pas léger mais
c'est bon alors on va parler de ce vin
rouge que vous nous avez
conseiller qui est un coteau du génois
donc on est dans on est dans la loi avec
comme cépages du Gamet et du pinot noir
et
oui c'est les seuls argile au calcaire
ça c'est un millésime 2009 2019 et
particularités c'est une robe rouge
intense reflet reflet violet qu'on
trouve là-bas note de griotte ou que de
cerise on va le goûter on va voir si on
si on retrouve exactement ça
alors là je sens pas la queue de cerise
parce que j'ai jamais goûté une queue
là c'est le moment où en fait dans les
mondanités quand on y connaît rien on
dit oui je trouve ça très bon j'aime
beaucoup je bois modérément c'est aussi
une question de génération c'est à dire
que je pense que on parle souvent avec
les anciens politiques ici même dans
l'Assemblée nationale
dans le Loiret moi sur le gatine il y
avait eu 20 mais le phylloxéra a eu
raison de tout au fin du 19e donc il y a
plus rien il y a une petite association
qui essaie de se bouger pour essayer de
replanter et ce côté du génois alors là
je l'ai pris en rouge parce que c'était
pour le plat ce qui permettant avec du
sauvignon dans ces cas-là je préfère le
blanc il est alors je crois c'est
l'essentiel de la production en tous les
cas dans tous les cas il est très bon je
suis pas suffisamment spécialiste pour
confirmer c'est quoi la queue de cerise
et cerise et grillades
qui disent ça mais il est très bon il
est très bon
tomate farcie en fait il y a souvent cet
accord des couleurs alors là pour le
coup le rouge de la tomate et le on peut
pas faire mieux donc là c'est un sans
faute on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable maintenant sur le reste c'est
le quiz
alors Thomas ménager vous rejoignez deux
boules à France en 2014 et effectivement
debout c'est souvent comme ça qu'on
avale un sandwich au comptoir alors
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sur ce sandwich un totem de
la cuisine française ou de la street
food française sont vrais ou fausse le
terme sandwich tire son origine d'une
petite ville de la petite ville de
sandwich dans le Kent en Angleterre
sandwich tire son origine de la petite
ville de sandwich dans le Kent je veux
dire vrai oui alors vrai
pour être plus précis c'est du conte de
John montagout qui était le conte de
sandwich et qui aimait beaucoup jouer et
pour gagner du temps à la table de jeu
il se faisait livrer deux petites
tranches il avait fait son petit
sandwich
le premier sandwich de l'histoire un tel
qu'on l'a identifié et composé de deux
tranches de pain qui entoure une couche
de
je vais dire faux parce que j'espère pas
pour ceux qui deviennent manger voilà et
bien oui c'était effectivement des
tranches de pain et des fines tranches
de viande de bœuf c'est le sandwich
c'est mondialisé sous l'influence de
chaîne comme Subway aux États-Unis des
1900 je crois que c'est très ancien donc
je veux dire vrai non faim Subway
démocratiser le sandwich mais c'était
plus vieux c'était en 1965 et enfin le
sandwich parisien qui est dans une
baguette comme celle-ci apparaît au
comptoir de la capitale en 1950
vous êtes né un 6 janvier sauf erreur de
ma part jour de l'épiphanie donc de la
fameuse galette des rois seriez-vous
nous dire si ces affirmations concernant
cette galette sont vrais ou fausses
alors ah au 16e siècle la galette
apparaît chez les boulangers pour faire
concurrence au gâteau des rois produits
par les pâtissiers
c'est vrai c'est vrai B sous Louis XII
la grande dame de la cour qui avait la
fève avait l'insigne honneur de devenir
reine de France pendant une heure
j'espère que c'est faux parce que là
franchement ça serait vraiment
inquiétant
alors sous la Révolution jugeait la
galette anti civique et la fève fut
remplacée par une mini guillotine en
porcelet
de mes collègues qu'on fasse ce genre de
parler mais non là vous avez raison faux
la femme était en forme de quand même
c'est un peu rude vous faites aider la
galette des Rois est célébrée
officiellement la première fois à
l'Elysée en 1972 où Georges Pompidou
est-ce que ça date de Pompidou je vais
je vais dire vrai c'était sous VGE
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing en 1975 vous
voyez ça date
je mange une galette depuis que je suis
né tous les ans et c'était le gâteau
d'anniversaire et j'en ai eu ras-le-bol
assez vite pour être honnête j'adore la
galette j'adore la galette frangipane
mais objectivement je rêvais quand
j'étais petit d'avoir un gâteau au
chocolat comme tous mes copains mais on
disait ah bah non c'est c'est pour des
rois il y a pas le choix on va pas on va
pas casser les traditions donc là sur ce
coup-là j'étais favorable à casser les
tradition donc maintenant objectivement
j'en mange mais le jour de mon
anniversaire souvent j'aime bien faire
autre chose
incroyable je les ai jamais
collectionner donc mais mais j'avoue
j'en aurai plus j'aurais pu les voir
évoluer j'aurais pu faire un historique
des fèves au moins depuis ma naissance
alors vous savez qu'en France le repas
occupe une assez large place et
particulièrement en politique c'est
souvent là que ce nous les deals
politiques est-ce que se fait la petite
et la grande Histoire et c'est la brève
de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé Thomas ménager
de vous souvenir d'un oui d'un souvenir
sur autour d'un repas en politique
est-ce que vous avez une histoire à nous
raconter alors un repas strict au sens
une non mais l'importance de la
nourriture dans mes souvenirs dans dans
mon imaginaire moi c'est en fait c'est
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
Marine Le Pen donc c'est vraiment très
politique c'est en 2017 pendant la
négociation de l'accord avec Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan j'étais son chef de
criminel à l'époque donc j'ai participé
à cette négociation et nos négociations
à deux reprises se sont passées autour
d'une énorme panière corbeille de
framboise alors je sais pas si c'était
de saison je pense pas vu la date des
élections et et bizarrement bizarrement
ça m'a marqué et ça m'a marqué
au point de demander à ce que quand elle
discute voilà c'est juste parce que ça
s'était trouvé comme ça qu'il y avait
des framboises etc sur le lieu où on se
trouvait et les deux fois et et
étrangement mais j'en ai déjà reparlé
avec Jean-Philippe Tanguy était présent
ou avec avec Nicolas Dupont-Aignan aussi
j'adore parler avec Marine Le Pen si
elle se souvient de son côté des
framboises mais bizarrement j'ai
souvenir de manger ses framboises parce
que c'était un moment important moi
j'étais un petit jeune en politique
j'étais assez impressionné de rencontrer
la personnalité 14 Le Pen qui est quand
même une personnalité impressionnante au
demeurant et donc c'est framboises alors
c'est pas un repas en tant que tel mais
ça m'a marqué comme quoi la nourriture
parfois dans un certain nombre de
moments Marc et marque une empreinte
dans notre cerveau mais ça avait tourné
au vinaigre finalement exactement ça
allait un peu mal fini et ça avait
participé à la fois à ma connaissance de
Marine Le Pen mon envie de la rejoindre
et puis mon incompréhension parfois la
stratégie de mon ancien mon ancien
patron
alors maintenant on va parler de
l'élevage
c'est du moins ce que préconise
de la Cour des comptes alors on profite
quelle alimentation c'est le dessous des
plats
la Cour des comptes a en effet rendu un
rapport explosif en préconisant de
réduire le nombre de vaches en France
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique l'élevage est responsable à
lui seul de près de 12% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre les éleveurs ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille
reportage m'a été Frémont Marion
desvauxchères
[Musique]
Hello Kitty on a tous les noms avec mes
filles et mes filles ils aident leur
maman à trouver des noms et des prénoms
et des bêtes sont à moins de 50 mètres
de la maison
parce que c'est des bêtes c'est notre
capital on les aime je suis François
henneo agriculteur dans le Loiret on a
repris avec mon épouse hors 4 familial
donc on est parti de 2-0 on s'est battu
croyait notre projet et puis voilà et
aujourd'hui ça fait 14 15 ans 15 ans
qu'on est ça va tellement vite que on
est installé et on commence à sortir la
tête de l'eau
alors que François commence tout juste à
s'en sortir financièrement tombe le
rapport de la Cour des comptes son
cheptel de 300 bovins serait-il trop
imposant que reproche-t-on concrètement
au 17000 vaches françaises
et en faisant des
une sorte de renvoi en fait ça crée des
gaz dans la planète et apparemment ça
pollurait plus que certaines usines
les vaches émettent 12% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre le méthane est 80
fois supérieur au gaz carbonique le
bétail coupable de réchauffer la planète
pour François l’élevage est bénéfique
pour l'environnement chaque année les
prairies stockent 8 millions de tonnes
de CO2 et c'est de tonnes de fumier sont
transformés en source d'énergie
partent en méthanisation on fait partie
nous on en fait partie depuis une
dizaine d'années pour polluer une
certaine façon de parler avec nos vaches
mais on recrée du gaz vert aussi cette
préconisation est un non-sens selon lui
c'est pourtant un engagement de la
France la réduction de 30% d'ici 7 ans
de ses émissions de méthane
disons-le clairement oui l'élevage bovin
devra prendre toute sa part dans la
transition agricole nous devons baisser
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mener notre transition agricole et
accompagner la structuration des
filières il y a une question de
souveraineté alimentaire puisque si
demain on a une quantité de viande et de
lait produite qui diminuent en France il
faut absolument que en cohérence nos
régimes alimentaires évoluent sinon ça
se traduira simplement par plus
d'importations et là on sera perdant sur
les deux tableaux moins manger de viande
la Cour des comptes préconise 500
grammes par semaine maximum alors que le
français en consomme aujourd'hui
232 g par jour
alors Thomas ménager est-ce qu'il faut
réduire le cheptel bovin pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique ça a
été très bien dit dans le dans le
reportage oui sur le papillon pourrait
se dire on réduit les gaz à effet de
serre bon on oublie aussi tout l'intérêt
des prairies ça a été très bien expliqué
mais derrière si c'est pour importer on
va pas non plus claquer des doigts
forcément ne plus manger de beurre puis
manger de lait boire de lait plus manger
de viande alors bien sûr il faut évoluer
en partie sur nos modes de consommation
on mangeait peut-être moins mieux
développer le circuit court mais une
incohérence aujourd'hui là moi je bosse
actuellement sur une mission
d'information sur les accords de
libre-échange on voit qu'il y a une
incohérence c'est-à-dire qu'on est très
heureux en France de se dire on réduit
nos émissions mais si on le fait à
l'autre bout de la planète c'est pas
comme le nuage de Tchernobyl ça va pas
s'arrêter donc il faut qu'il y ait une
cohérence d'ensemble et aujourd'hui je
considère que faut pas tomber dans cet
agribashing il faut peut-être évoluer
sur un certain nombre de méthodes ça va
aussi
enfin dire que il y aura moins d'élevage
non peut-être mais il faut déjà que les
Français en ait envie qu'il puisse le
faire et après il faut se donner la
possibilité il faut donner la
possibilité de de pour des questions de
santé il faut peut-être revoir un peu
notre régime alimentaire en partie on
consomme peut-être un peu trop de viande
rouge on peut peut-être évoluer mais
dans tous les cas il faut donner la
capacité à ces personnes à ces
agriculteurs de vivre parce que
aujourd'hui ils sont déjà en difficulté
et s'ils ont augmenté certains la taille
de leur cheptel c'est parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à vivre dans leur
situation dans la situation actuelle
donc aujourd'hui
cet agriculteur si aujourd'hui vous si
demain vous lui réduites réduisez moitié
son cheptel il pourra plus vivre et puis
derrière il y aura plus tout ce qu'il y
a et ce qui fait vivre aussi notre
réalité parce qu'en fait c'est encore un
sacrifice dans notre ruralité
c'est-à-dire que c'est encore la réalité
qui va mourir si on mangeait 500 g ce
qui est préconisé par les autorités de
santé bien finalement il y aurait pas de
perte de souveraineté pour la France
ça reste à prouvé après si on veut
vraiment agir sur les gaz à effet de
serre on sait que
d'autres leviers
qui nourrit en partie notre bétail c'est
un soja qui est importé et c'est des
centaines de milliers de tonnes voire de
millions de tonnes de CO2 parce qu'on
n'a pas notre de cette capacité de
souveraineté alimentaire vis-à-vis de la
nourriture pour pour ce bétail donc il y
a peut-être d'autres leviers que
purement et simplement dire aux
agriculteurs on va diviser par deux
votre cheptel et qui doivent pas quand
même faire des efforts c'est quand même
le deuxième émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre derrière les transports
l'agriculture est-ce qu'il doit pas au
moins qu'il y ait des comportements plus
vertueux
essayer de trouver des solutions mais
bien sûr je pense que les agriculteurs
ils sont tous favorables ils cherchent
tous des solutions il y a personne qui
est ultra heureux de polluer pour
polluer parce que souvent en plus alors
coûte cher quand on parle de ces
importations il préférait peut-être
avoir la capacité à à produire la
nourriture pour leur bétail sur place et
donc éviter ce type de de pollution de
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre ce
qui est certain c'est que je pense qu'il
faut éviter le côté un peu forcé de
certains qui rendent un rapport qui
disent bon bah oui mathématiquement si
on divise par deux il y en aura deux
fois moins et ça sera possible
si on force pas un peu les agriculteurs
non mais après qui est dit peut-être des
recommandations qui ne volonté mais je
vous dis on pourra pas le faire non plus
contre les Français ils ont besoin de
yaourts ils ont besoin de lait ils ont
besoin de viande et puis derrière il y a
des gens qui ont besoin de vivre de leur
travail concrètement comment comment on
fait et nous dans nos campagnes il y a
déjà moins en moins d'agriculture c'est
ce que je veux dire cela dit il faut
bien se rendre compte c'est qu'il y a de
moins en moins d'élevage depuis des
décennies donc déjà la baisse est
tendancière inéluctable donc est-ce que
c'est pas juste la continuité d'un
processus et peut-être l'aménager et
l'encadrer mais l'élevage baisse de
toute façon je suis d'accord je crois
qu'il y a eu 30 ans 30 ou 40 % de baisse
de l'élevage en viande en lait parce
qu'ils peuvent plus vivre de leur
travail donc plutôt que se poser la
question de forcer
les modes de vie ouais mais on importe
on importe on importe
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui m'inquiète
c'est que si on produit on a un cheptel
qui se réduit en France mais qu'on
apporte de la viande du CETA avec le
CETA du Canada aujourd'hui qu'on le fait
demain si on signe avec le Mercosur
pour pour l'agneau aujourd'hui on est
sur des débats sur la question de la
Nouvelle-Zélande la nouvelle accord
européen il y a une incohérence totale
parce qu'en plus au-delà de la
consommation et de la production de gaz
à effet de serre on rajoute le transport
dans ces et on a aussi certains pays
c'est pas forcément le cas pour pour
l'agneau pour la Nouvelle-Zélande mais
qui ont aussi des techniques de
production qui ne sont pas aussi
vertueuses que celles que nous avons en
France et nous n'avons pas la capacité
de les contrôler donc il faut peut-être
faire continuer à participer mes
agriculteurs ils font déjà énormément
d'efforts ils veulent continuer à le
faire il faut les accompagner mais il
faut qu'ils puissent de leur travail une
transition comme le disait Jean-Pierre
et quelle transition est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il qui plante des panneaux solaires
est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils aient qu'il
fasse de la méthanisation aussi à côté
quand comment on fait bien sûr ça fait
partie de la diversification qui peuvent
avoir moi mais par contre moi je dis
toujours et j'ai le même discours avec
mes agriculteurs dans le Loiret c'est
qu'ils doivent dresser des agriculteurs
c'est à dire qu'ils doivent
faire évoluer les pratiques les
agriculteurs en premier nous
rassemblement national aussi mais il
faut le faire de manière concertée de
manière forcée aujourd'hui dans une
volonté un peu un peu violente dans les
changements Thomas ménager que dit un
député comme vous un jeune éleveur qui
veut se monter aujourd'hui qui dit qu'il
y ait plein d'entrains qui est adepte
d'une nouvelle économie qui veut du
nouvel écologie d'une dans l'agriculture
et qui veut se lancer qu'est-ce que vous
lui dites comme discours bah je lui
dissuader
essaie de dissuade pas parce que c'est
ça c'est ce qui fait vivre notre
territoire alors bien entendu l'élevage
de l'agriculture globalement dans nos
territoires ruraux à moins de poids
qu'on peut l'avoir par le passé avant ça
faisait vraiment vivre le village mais
bien entendu je l'encourage et aussi ils
ont changé l'encourager avec des avec
des en lui disant attention il va
falloir faire attention à ça il va
falloir ils ont transformé ton pays ton
métier
elle est née dedans comme moi à l'école
ils vivent pas en dehors du monde et
même si les parents parfois ont eu des
techniques des méthodes déjà les parents
évolué parce que plus ça leur coûte cher
souvent les méthodes qui étaient les
plus chimiques celles qui polluent le
plus souvent elles ont un coût donc même
s'ils ont pas des considérations
purement écologiques il y a des
considérations économiques financières
mais les jeunes souvent j'étais au lycée
du chinois qui a un lycée agricole qui
est le deuxième plus gros de France sur
mon territoire les plus anciens de
France ils ont changé ils veulent faire
de l'écoute tourisme ils veulent faire
de la vente à la faire ils veulent
développer des activités ils veulent pas
être l'agriculteur
comme par le passé ils veulent souvent
même être parfois pas l'agriculteur des
parents c'est-à-dire qu'ils veulent
avoir d'autres activités changer le
modèle
il se renouvelle un peu parce que ça
fait aussi tourner les sols c'est bon
pour l'université et puis moi je crois
beaucoup au progrès je crois beaucoup à
la recherche c'est à dire je crois pas
forcément aux côtés violent en disant on
réduit comme ça on coupe par de les
cheptel et comme ça on va arriver le
problème il y a des techniques il y a de
la recherche c'est le cas et on en
parlera peut-être sur les
néonicotinoïdes je pense que personne
est heureux de mettre des pesticides de
mettre des produits chimiques mais
derrière il faut qu'on ait le temps que
la recherche et les moyens de trouver
des alternatives souvent on met pas les
moyens et du coup la recherche n'avance
pas et
soit de bonne volonté c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut pas que les agriculteurs mais c'est
pas c'est pas le cas pour l'essentiel se
disent bon on va pousser des dérogations
on va pousser pousser la plupart du
temps c'est le cas sur on en parlera
tout à l'heure mais il y a des il y a
des travaux de recherche en parallèle
alors peut-être que les pouvoirs publics
doivent les accompagner de manière plus
importante pour éviter qu'on soit
souvent peut-être parfois au pied du mur
et et de forcer cette ces changements
politiques agricole qui est menée là
aujourd'hui par le ministère elle va
dans le bon sens elle a accompagne
suffisamment vers cette transition ou
pas moi ce que je constate ce que je
constate surtout c'est qu'en fait on vit
on subit un dumping environnemental et
c'est souvent ce que les agriculteurs
nous disent c'est à dire que c'est le
cas sur sur la question de nicotinerie
c'est qu'on en parlera mais c'est un
exemple très criant c'est le fait que
dans d'autres pays européens il y a un
certain nombre de molécules qui ne sont
pas interdites c'est-à-dire même au
niveau européen on accepte sur notre sol
des produits il y a des disparités on se
tire une balle dans le pied toujours les
Français on veut laver plus blanc que
blanc on va en faire des caisses et au
final c'est néfastes alors je peux
comprendre la politique agricole qui est
menée aujourd'hui non je la soutiens pas
parce que malheureusement alors il y a
certaines points sur lequel on peut on
peut on peut se retrouver mais sur la
question de l'élevage dans tous les cas
je ne sais pas ce qui sera décidé par le
gouvernement et j'espère qu'ils suivront
pas la Cour des comptes
sujet une politique de décroissance hors
des réalités donc
voilà il a pas cité là c'est un local de
l'État
je pense qu'il connaît il est élu près
de marche noir qui a un territoire rural
il sait très bien que
on élève pas des vaches pour polluer
c'est parce que derrière ça nourrit et
que derrière s'il y a des évolutions de
pratique c'est une chose mais si c'est
des évolutions sur le sol français mais
qu'on importe ça sera une folie ça sera
encore favori après il faut avoir dans
les actes sur la question par exemple
des Nico ninoïdes j'aurais espéré qu'il
soit beaucoup plus beaucoup offensif et
qui ne se laisse pas dicter au niveau
européen un certain nombre de
réglementations et il faut absolument
éviter
cette hypocrisie totale de on interdit
des produits sur notre sol mais on
importe des produits qui ne respectent
pas ces règles il faut une réciprocité
il faut des clauses miroirs aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des accords ont été pensés
notamment les accords de libre-échange
uniquement sous le prisme de la balance
commerciale alors c'est super oui on va
peut-être exporter un certain nombre de
produits ouvrir un certain nombre de
marché mais derrière s'il y a pas ces
clauses miroirs ces obligations de
respecter il y a des considérations
sanitaires économiques environnementales
et sociales qui sont qui sont en jeu
donc bien entendu il faut qu'on change
notre paradigme sur ces questions vous
avez parlé plusieurs fois des
néonicotinoïdes on va parler du coût de
la culture de la betterave qui est
menacée par la fin de ces insecticides
certains continuent de défendre pourtant
ce pesticide pour sauver la filière on
en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat
oui brigitte c'est une année
particulière pour les producteurs de
betteraves qui n'auront plus le droit
donc d'utiliser ces puissances
insecticides pour éradiquer les pucerons
dévastateurs pour les récoltes après
deux ans de dérogation la Cour de
justice européenne a tranché finit
terminé les exceptions c'est un
reportage dans le Loiret et ses environs
de Diane Kruger Moore et de Marie
Duvauchelle
dans son champ Alexandre Pelé aime
toujours à trouver des coccinelles
bonne nouvelle car elle mange les
pucerons les ennemis jurés de ces
betteraves sucrières il leur
transmettent le virus de la jaunisse
synonyme de mort certaine et pour cet
agriculteur de récolte ravagées d'autant
plus que cette année il ne peut plus
compter sur les néonicotinoïdes pour
s'en prémunir un gros risque pour son
exploitation on peut pas se permettre de
d'implanter une culture parce qu'on met
beaucoup d'argent et puis derrière
d'avoir un rendement qui est aléatoire
et une sur trois une année sur deux une
année sur 5 perdre de l'argent quoi
avant même la récolte prévue pour la fin
de l'année cet agriculteur se sent
désarmés sans Arsenal chimique la
meilleure solution technique économique
aujourd'hui reste les néonics donc voilà
aujourd'hui moi je juge que les les
outils techniques dont on dispose ne
sont pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on avait
auparavant quoi assurer de haut
rendement pour maintenir une filière
sucrière française c'est la priorité des
producteurs mais pour ce chercheur au
CNRS l'argument ne tient pas car même en
prenant en compte les mauvaises années
la production est déjà très élevée trois
fois supérieure aux années 60 on est
arrivé au maximum de ce qu'on pouvait
produire en matière de betterave
sucrière en utilisant l'agriculture
intensive et les pesticides
néonicotinoïdes il alerte sur les effets
dévastateurs des néonicotinoïdes sur
l'environnement pollution des sols des
eaux contamination des abeilles des
poissons
la santé humaine est aussi menacée pour
lui les betteraviers doivent faire leur
révolution comme l’ont déjà fait les
cultivateurs de maïs ça demande un peu
plus de travail ça demande un peu plus
d'investissement et c'est peut-être un
peu moins rentable mais à un moment
donné il faut se poser la question
qu'est-ce qu'on veut est-ce qu'on veut
une filière betterave très forte au
détriment de l'environnement de la
biodiversité et de la santé s'adapter
c'est ce qu'on tente de faire dans cette
ferme pilote Rodolphe couturier essaye
dans son champ une nouvelle méthode les
plantes compagnent là il s'agit d'un
pied de féverole qui est
une plante qui se développe qui fait des
grosses feuilles et qui permet d'attirer
beaucoup de pucerons en fait et donc
l'idée c'est de dire il faut que c'est
pucerons faut garder le moins possible
qui arrive sur les betteraves si les
buissons viennent sur d'autres plantes
et ben en attendant ils auront pas
transmettre le virus à la betterave
autre solution expérimentée ici des
phéromones pour éloigner les pucerons ou
des variétés de betteraves plus
résistantes à l'âgeonis ces petits qu'au
départ cette agriculteur s'est pris au
jeu il y aura pas de miracle au bout de
la troisième année je me dis qu'il y a
quand même des choses qui peuvent
peut-être amener un peu de souplesse ces
expérimentations vont encore durer
plusieurs mois avant de peut-être
généraliser les solutions trouvées
alors Thomas ménager ma question est
volontairement provocatrice mais est-ce
que c'est betteravier ne crie pas avant
d'avoir mal en fait ça dépend parce
qu'en fait on peut pas envisager et
savoir s'il y aura beaucoup de pucerons
donc beaucoup de jaunissent donc
peut-être que cette année par chance en
l'absence de néonicotinoïdes
mais c'est l'incertitude de la nature
dans votre circonscription par exemple
moi surtout il y a une baisse certains
sont dit maintenant en fait
l'incertitude c'est un risque un risque
financier alors souvent ils avaient une
diversité bien sûr c'est pas des
agriculteurs
il y en a qui ont diminue fortement et
la plupart trop risqué c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des cultures qui sont plus
rentables moins risquées et aujourd'hui
quand l'élément risque
augmenté accentué parce qu'ils avaient
déjà un risque parce que néonicotinoïdie
c'était pas la panasée ça n'arrivait pas
tous les problèmes il y a eu certaines
années un certain temps de
problématiques mais bien dopé la
production et ça amélioré quand même et
et ça limite
quand même l'essentiel des
problématiques après si tout se passe
bien cette année parce que que la météo
parce que la reproduction la
reproduction des pucerons se passe bien
c'est une bonne chose mais il y a dans
tous les cas un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui ont abandonné ce que
je constate par contre vous auriez aimé
une année dérogation en plus j'aurais
aimé parce que vous voyez il bosse
à avancer ben il y a un moment on peut
pas révolutionner des mécanismes
c'est-à-dire que le ministre c'était
marcéno les ministres c'était engagé
c'est la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne qui a décidé de nous taper
sur la tête et là encore on élargit le
champ mais la question de la
souveraineté et des choix que nous
faisons sur notre sol en la matière ne
devrait pas souffrir de telles décisions
mais aujourd'hui en France chaque année
il y a une baisse la décision de la Cour
de justice
au gouvernement français de décider s'il
donner cette année supplémentaire et
cette dérogation supplémentaire dans
tous les cas ça va coûter aux Français
parce que c'est dérogation indirectement
comme il y a plus cette dérogation il y
aura sûrement des indemnisations si
jamais et je croise les doigts je touche
du bois il y a pas une bonne production
puisque dans tous les cas la première
compenser elle est prévue
l'accompagnement non mais qui a un
accompagnement puisqu'il y a eu cette
décision qui a été brutale en fait aussi
pour voir le contexte on vous dit
pendant des années vous aurez 3 ans il
bosse oui il commence à avancer il le
disent dans le reportage on approche on
commence à avoir des solutions il y a
les il y a alors il y a la question
génétique NBT il y a des plans de
campagne il y a des des mécanismes de
biochimie
et donc il y a du boulot mais quand au
mois de janvier alors que vous plantez
fin janvier quand vous plantez au mois
de mars
dans un certain nombre de pays on a
encore des capacités
en amont voilà c'est c'est alors c'est
ça alors il y avait des débat parce que
si les la betterave ne fleurit pas alors
peut-être qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de reliquats de reste dans les
terres qui pouvaient entraîner un
certain nombre de de sur les plantes
suivantes de créer des problèmes mais
moi je suis dans un territoire sur le du
miel je vous en parlais il y a
énormément de colonies et objectivement
il y a d'autres problématiques mais
c'était pas non plus majeur d'abeilles
donc c'est vrai que c'est paradoxal
d'aller défendre le miel
attention les néonicotinoïdes c'est ça
là pour les betteraves c'est une semence
enrobée alors c'était peut-être pas
parfait parce qu'il peut y avoir des
flaques d'eau qui est contenaient encore
des néonicotinoïdes il pouvait y avoir
peut-être pour les plantes suivantes qui
étaient des plantes mellifères je sais
pas du colza vous savez que les
rotations des cultures des
problématiques mais elles étaient quand
même il y avait pas de risque c'est ce
que vous dites il était très très limité
personne chez moi dans les apiculteurs
me disait on a un gros gros problème si
on peut s'en passer une bonne chose par
contre la pulvérisation et aujourd'hui
il y a plusieurs néonicotinoïdes il y a
notamment l'acétamyride qui est autorisé
encore dans d'autres pays européens
c'est-à-dire que en Allemagne notamment
posé des questions comment vous
l'expliquez ça on parlait disparité
et c'est un des types de néonicotinoïdes
petite ça pour nous parce que parce que
non mais elle a décidé pour eux aussi
mais en fait c'est pas forcément les
mêmes molécules et nous en fait là cet
ami Pride il y a pas il y a plusieurs
molécules en fait le problème c'est que
c'est très technique les néonicotinoïdes
il y en a plusieurs types et nous on a
été plus loin par la loi climat et
résilience je crois en 2016 s'il m'avait
boire est bonne et on sait on a interdit
la pulvérisation de la stabilité donc
voilà il y a aussi d'autres solutions je
sais très bien que en fait c'est une
question de temps il faut laisser du
temps alors c'est un équilibre bien sûr
vous avez raison entre
laisser croire que en fait on pourra
repousser indéfiniment et à un moment
prendre des décisions un mois ou deux
mois avant les semis le glyphosate par
exemple ça a été reconduit pour 5 ans et
donc là mon la question va se reposer à
nouveau est-ce que ça va pas être à
nouveau reconduit après les règles du
jeu et la recherche n'avance pas tant
que c'est reconduit enfin ou en tout cas
moi j'avais raison mais quand tes règles
du jeu sont clairs encore c'est parfois
difficile et parfois on y arrive pas
forcément et ça sera peut-être difficile
dans 5 ans et on fera le bilan
mais là c'est pire que tout c'est à dire
qu'on a changé les règles du jeu en
cours de jeu en cours de partie c'est
au-delà de ça
ils peuvent se passer des niveaux ni
côté nihuides et avoir des semences qui
ne sont pas enrobés ça sera peut-être
des semences qui seront moins cher ils
seront très heureux parce que ça peut
créer un certain nombre de
problématiques environnementales ils
aiment leur territoire ils aiment la
nature ils aiment l'environnement et ça
leur coûte un fric monstre aussi
d'utiliser ces pesticides mais voilà il
y a vraiment une contradiction cette
année pour information en Pologne et en
Allemagne les surfaces se dire ceux qui
ont encore des capacités peut-être
d'insecticides en pulvérisation que nous
nous sommes interdits ont augmenté leur
surface en betterave par un effet
d'aubaine ça bien que la France qui
était quand même le leader en la matière
à sa production qui qui va diminuer et
nous on baisse donc il y a quand même
une réflexion à avoir c'est à dire qu'il
y ait une coordination réelle au niveau
européen ou qu'on nous laisse le choix
de décider nous-mêmes ce que nous
souhaitons ou pas pour notre agriculture
la semaine dernière on reçoit avec
Brigitte marine Tondelier qui on va dans
le mur
vous laissez du temps à la recherche
vous étiez prêt à une nouvelle
dérogation est-ce que finalement entre
la protection de la biodiversité la
course au rendement il n'y a pas deux
mondes de vision de l'agriculture qui
s'affrontent encore je pense pas et je
pense qu'il faut éviter cette opposition
c'est une ligne de crête bien entendu
comment je disais tout à l'heure de
savoir à quel endroit on pose le curseur
il faut faire évoluer nos pratiques mais
je pense que l'agriculture quand même
souffre il suffit de voir le baisse des
exploitations tant végétal que que que
en viande en élevage il faut pas qu'on
le fasse de manière forcée et brutale
mais il faut quand même être proactif
donc c'est un équilibre c'est un
équilibre on va être pas en mode laisser
aller on s'en fout parce qu'il y a des
vrais problématiques environnementales
des vrais problèmes
et surtout il faut le faire sans
hypocrisie sans prendre les gens pour
des idiots c'est à dire pas se dire que
on va mais c'est sur d'autres sujets sur
la zéro artificialisation net des terres
agricoles mais en même temps laisser des
usines qu'on pourra peut-être pas
installer sur notre sol parce qu'on aura
plus la capacité de les relocaliser et
se dire que au final 50% de vous avez
fait de serre sont liées aux
importations mais c'est la même
problématique il faut avoir une vision
globale une vision générale de la
question et surtout d'éviter de se dire
c'est toujours à la France alors c'est
bien c'est ce que vous dites quoi il
faut pas en faire trop par rapport aux
autres pays si vous souhaitez mais il
faut trouver justement être bon élève
mais que ça ça nuit à votre peuple ben
un moment et à vos agriculteurs à votre
réalité en disant c'est toute la filière
sucre qui va s'effondrer alors là on n'a
pas l'impression que toutes les usines
de sucrière ferment est-ce que c'est le
cas est-ce que vous vous l'avez constaté
dans votre territoire il y a quelques
années il y en a déjà une première
une première usine qui a fermé bien sûr
ouais moi aujourd'hui il y avait 100 je
crois une centaine dans les années 50 de
de d'usine de de betterave à sucre pour
de sucreries chercher le mot de
sucreries aujourd'hui il y en a plus
qu'une vingtaine en France
ça vient d'être parce qu'il y a il y a
un mécanisme mouvement plus profond là
il y a un mécanisme clairement la
betterave c'était pas quelque chose le
plus rentable c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un
dans votre un chercheur qui disait il
faut qu'ils acceptent que ça soit moins
rentable objectivement c'était
absolument pas la culture la plus
rentable c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu une
diminution elle est compliquée elle est
technique et là on ajoute des
problématiques assez difficultés
économique et technique
il y a un risque moyen il y a une
sucrerie qui est importante c'est celle
de corbeille chez moi qui fait vivre
tout le territoire c'est pas seulement
les betteraves c'est pendant toute la
campagne à l'étranger ou pas non non
mais en fait petit à petit bah il a eu
la fermeture d'autres sucreries et on a
récupéré en fait le malheur des uns et
le bonheur des autres dans un premier
temps parce qu'on récupère les
productions c'est-à-dire que ça a
diminué sur notre territoire mais on va
aller un peu plus loin Seine-et-Marne
etc on cherchais mais petit à petit
c'est des outils qui coûtent 10 15
millions d'euros qui parfois sont
démantelés et partent à l'étranger en
plus parce que c'est sous-titres
techniques importants et ça fait vivre
tout un bassin moi ça fait vivre les les
bars les restaurants dans un village ça
fait tout un territoire il y a tous ceux
qui font la campagne avec les camions et
donc faut éviter de tuer aussi notre
ruralité c'est toujours cette équilibre
qu'il faut trouver bien entendu ça peut
nous coûter notre place de premier
producteurs de betteraves en Europe ou
pas alors je me souviens plus des
chiffres pour pouvoir prendre une telle
position mais dans tous les cas on est
en baisse et d'autres sont en hausse
parce qu'ils ont des possibilités
chimiques que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui mais il y a quand même des
sources d'espoir et le progrès est là je
sais qu'en Australie il y a une molécule
qui a été autorisée je sais que le
ministre que j'avais sollicité sur cette
question et c'est d'activer et
d'accélérer l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché de ce produit donc elle
l'espoir mais l'espoir c'est la
recherche je pense la science on va
continuer à parler du sucre et on va à
en manger c'est le péché mignon
et pour le sucré c'est une tarte tatin
ma chère Brigitte une préparation
réussie à l'insulte leur plein gré par
les fameuses sortes atteintes sur Thomas
ménager Koné l'histoire puisque vous
connaissez la légende urbaine qui a fait
le succès de cette tarte une des sœurs a
laissé tomber la tarte et pour sauver
les apparences et bien la racommoder ça
en leur mettant à l'envers et à la serre
elle avait lancé la cuisson et puis elle
s'est dit allez je balance la pâte
brisée dessus donc je sais pas dans tous
les cas c'est au moins ça je pense quand
même le symbole alors est-ce que c'est
vrai ou est-ce que c'est totalement une
légende que des fois on peut se planter
comment politique des fois on peut se
rattraper aux branches on essaie
toujours se dire qu'on fait le mieux je
pense que c'est ce qu'ils ont essayé de
faire au début dans la recette en
faisant la tarte aux pommes elle s'est
rendu compte qu'elle s'était plantée et
l'idée elle a essayé de rattraper et
donc voilà on est pas certain toujours
de réussir mais l'objectif c'est
d'essayer de faire disparaître
qui est qu'on faisait régulièrement à la
maison que je fais encore je vais faire
mon caramel de mettre mes pommes pas
tous les jours j'ai pas faire croire moi
souvent je suis pas fan avec la crème
fouettée alors c'est sympa aussi moi je
pourrais même franchement moi je préfère
la boule de glace vanille avec le
chaud-froid j'aime bien j'aime bien le
mélange des deux et quelle pâte sur les
pommes brisés brisé ouais brise vous
utilisez une pomme pas trop facile à la
maison voilà une pomme pas trop acide
qui a une chair qui qui va bien réagir
voilà souvent je prends des alors je
sais pas si c'est peut-être pas une
marque mais une pique Lady
c'est des pommes que j'aime bien qui
sont sucrées mais quand même assez ferme
mais qui tiennent bien la cuisson et
voilà avec une boule de glace le mélange
chaud froid il est pas je crois que
c'est
une pâte feuilletée alors moi je mets un
bruit est-ce que vous faites des
variantes parce que la tarte tatin elle
est aux pommes naturellement mais il y a
des tatin au coin qui peuvent être pas
mauvaises des attentes aux poires non
vous restez vous êtes taliban la tata
non non mais après ça va être super bon
le coin je suis pas très fan
personnellement j'adore c'est très bon
la tata ou quoi le coin pure c'est
compliqué moi je voilà avec de la pomme
ça passe mais mes poires pourquoi pas
j'ai jamais essayé j'aurais dû j'aurais
dû demander une variante pour essayer
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
et on se retrouve pour la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LCP